[Música]
Paraguay elegirá nuevo presidente este
domingo son los octavos comicios
generales en el país desde el fin de la
dictadura en 1989 y en los que también
se elegirá al congreso y a otras
autoridades locales
a propósito de las elecciones también
les contamos sobre la situación
económica de Paraguay su moneda el
guaraní es una de las más fuertes de
América Latina a pesar de la pandemia de
covid 19 y la inflación récord del
último
la resistencia a los antibióticos podría
dejar de ser un problema en el futuro
cercano en Costa Rica una investigación
encontró la clave en el pelaje de los
perezosos animales que nunca presentan
infecciones tras ser heridos les
contamos de qué se trata
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Paraguay el país se alista para las
elecciones generales de este domingo una
votación incierta e histórica que podría
acabar con El dominio del oficialista
partido Colorado 4.7 millones de
paraguayos están obligados a acudir a
las urnas marinas ardiña tiene los
detalles
camiones repletos de cajas con papeletas
urnas y cabinas de votación custodiadas
por el ejército todo está listo para los
octavos comicios desde el fin de la
dictadura en Paraguay camino hay un
candidato confiable
y no sé voy a ver qué hago porque no me
gusta este domingo casi cuatro ocho coma
millones de ciudadanos están llamados a
las urnas en la elección más incierta
sin segunda vuelta Los paraguayos votan
para renovar el poder ejecutivo
presidente vicepresidente y 17
gobernadores departamentales todo apunta
que pese a que hay 13 candidatos la
contienda se reñirá entre el conservador
Santiago peña del oficialista partido
Colorado y Efraín alegre centro
izquierdista al frente de la alianza
opositora la concertación con la que
pretende romper la hegemonía de las
últimas seis décadas de los Colorados
mis expectativas son que Que bueno que
gane el mejor y que pueda hacer resurgir
el Paraguay que que se preocupe por los
que somos los habitantes por nuestra
economía por nuestra salud por nuestra
educación de las urnas también saldrá la
conformación del legislativo compuesto
por 45 senadores y 80 diputados
distintas organizaciones internacionales
como la oea la misión de observación de
la Unión Europea o el parlamento del
mercosur acompañarán la jornada
electoral también 27.000 policías y
10.000 militares estarán desplegados por
el territorio para garantizar el libre
ejercicio del derecho al voto de los
electores paraguayos que están obligados
a votar o se enfrentarán a una multa
equivalente a un día de salario mínimo y
seguimos allí en Paraguay donde el
guaraní no solo es una de las monedas
más antiguas de América Latina también
es una de las más estables a pesar de la
inflación récord de los últimos dos años
causada por la pandemia y por el alza de
los precios del combustible nuestros
corresponsales reconstruyeron la
historia del guaraní creado en 1943
los precios asustan los guaraníes se
cuentan por millares pero cuando se hace
el cambio al Dólar no es para tanto la
mayoría de los productos en este mercado
viene de Argentina no el guaraní acá acá
la comparación de o sea el cambio con el
peso está buenísimo nuestro guaraní es
la moneda más estable de Sudamérica
como vos Y pase ha pasado muchas cosas
en el Paraguay pero por lo menos su
moneda sigue todavía estable
el museo de numismática en la sede del
Banco Central de Paraguay reconstruye la
historia de esta moneda que en Octubre
cumple 80 años
en nuestra historia es muy inestable con
muchas guerras internas y dos guerras
internacionales muy grandes que fueron
la de la Triple Alianza que fue una
pelea contra Argentina Brasil y este
Uruguay este conflicto aniquiló la mitad
de la población y mató al 90% de los
varones en edad militar paradójicamente
la inestabilidad política dio origen a
la moneda más estable de Sudamérica a
día de hoy no se sabe por qué decidieron
bautizarla con el nombre del pueblo
indígena lo que cuenta la gente es que
el decreto tenía que salir a la mañana y
a medianoche no sabían todavía Qué
nombre ponerle entonces ahí alguien se
le ocurrió y salió el nombre guaraní que
es en este momento la moneda cuya
denominación es la más antigua después
del peso colombiano verdad en América
Latina en el Banco Central confían en
que una eventual victoria de la
oposición no afectaría la moneda ya
hubieron un cambio político de cambio de
gobierno en la época de Lugo el doctor
Franco etcétera y la economía sigue por
su camino no creo que haya ningún
inconveniente con el guaraní el mercado
internacional en este momento es el que
más influencia tiene en este momento
para facilitar las transacciones
monetarias en 2009 surgió un proyecto
para quitar tres ceros al guaraní que da
por ver si el nuevo gobierno retomará un
proyecto que suscita dudas por miedo que
genere aún más inflación
en Bolivia una profesora imparte de
manera gratuita clases de natación a
niños con capacidades especiales una
idea que nació de sí misma ante la falta
de personal capacitado para poder
comunicarse con ella y ahora quiere
ayudar a estos menores a lograr una
mayor inclusión en la sociedad Rafael
Pérez nos cuenta más
el deporte como herramienta de inclusión
esta escuela en Bolivia enseña a nadar a
niños con discapacidad auditiva todo un
reto para la profesora que combina
movimientos no establecidos en el
lenguaje de señas con el método
tradicional de comunicación entre la
comunidad sordomuda estas clases son
importantes porque en Bolivia o en
nuestra provincia no existen
experiencias similares para que los
niños con alguna condición especial
puedan tener acceso a actividades
deportivas por la Barrera de la
comunicación en ocasiones la condición
de estos infantes no permite un
relacionamiento completo con la sociedad
la piscina se convierte en un vínculo
perfecto con su entorno por lo que la
práctica de este deporte los ayuda a
integrarse mejor mi hijo lleva tiempo en
las clases ya nada se está entra al agua
el tema de la anotación ha ayudado
bastante porque
es un deporte completo
le he ayudado
a desestresar eso sino los implementos
necesarios para ayudar a la audición la
experiencia puede desorientar a los
estudiantes los aprendices ponen todo su
empeño para avanzar la idea de estos
talleres surgió de la experiencia propia
de la profesora tardó más de 20 años
para aprender cómo defenderse en el agua
no había instructores capaces de
comunicarse con ella
cuando tenía 15 años quería pero no
podía aprender a nadar solo aprendí a
nadar en la escuela de profesores de
deportes luego ya estaba mayor estoy muy
agradecida con esa escuela y eso me
anima a ayudar a los niños Las clases
son completamente gratis y no solo
tienen como objetivo la inmersión de
niños con dificultades físicas en el
deporte también es un método para
desarrollar en la comunidad hábitos
saludables de vida
en Costa Rica un investigador ha
descubierto que el pelaje de los
perezosos podría servir para desarrollar
nuevos antibióticos ya que estos
mamíferos que viven en zonas tropicales
nunca presentan infecciones tras ser
heridos los nuevos medicamentos sacados
de los mamíferos ayudarían a luchar
contra la resistencia a los antibióticos
Andrés granadillo tiene los detalles
una mirada profunda y un paso lento
estos perezosos pueden ser la clave para
el desarrollo de los antibióticos del
futuro el científico Max Chavarría
observó que en su pelaje habitan
microorganismos que los ayudan a que
nunca se enfermen si uno ve por ejemplo
el pelaje de un perezoso uno ve un
movimiento uno ve polillas ve diferentes
tipos de insectos ven ve que es un un
sitio donde tenemos un hábitat muy muy
amplio Las investigaciones lograron
comprobar que las bacterias de estos
mamíferos pueden producir antibióticos
que regulan los agentes patógenos Pero
por qué no pensar más allá que
perfectamente esa molécula también
podría ser útiles
o puede ser Útil para para nosotros en
otro tipo de aplicaciones Como por
ejemplo en medicina en salud humana en
Costa Rica judy Avi una estadounidense
administra un santuario de perezosos
desde 1992 más de 1000 han pasado por el
lugar rescatados con heridas sin jamás
presentar infecciones
hemos recibido perezosos que habían sido
quemados por líneas eléctricas y cuyo
brazo completo fue destruido se puede
ver a través del pelo que la piel se
secó hasta el hueso y no hay infección
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
advierte que la resistencia de los
antibióticos podría causar 10 millones
de muertes cada año A mediados de siglo
descubrir nuevos es un tema de Vital
importancia este proyecto podría dar una
luz de Esperanza para el futuro de la
humanidad y sus próximas batallas contra
las infecciones y cerramos en México la
estrella española Rosalía deleito este
viernes a sus fanáticos con un concierto
en el icónico Zócalo de la capital del
país se esperaba que unas 200.000
personas asistieran al evento con el que
la llamada moto mami cierra su gira por
América así Rosalía se suma a leyendas
como Roger waters y Paul McCartney que
también se han presentado gratis en el
Zócalo
así despedimos este Informativo en
France 24 Gracias por acompañarnos
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]